Mnemosyne on in a compact lecithin
compact sedans are rare in Germany says
car tester Ronnie lipstick but Honda
still offers the Civic as a sedan
because it's retired the Accord now
we'll take Honda's mid-range sedan for a
spin this is the 10th generation of the
Civic that Honda's engineers have put on
the road six point three million civics
have been sold since 1973 and today the
car is built in nine plants across the
world the new version is 10 centimeters
longer and four and a half centimetres
wider than its predecessor little else
has changed
[Music]
avoid Ronnie says the Civic Sedan is
based on the compact platform but has a
much smoother ride than the hatchback
variant is just as agile but won't shake
you up as much on uneven road surfaces
give the credit to the variable steering
ratio says Ronnie it's like in the
hybrid super sports car Honda's NSX
drivers dream the steering wheel
provides a stable zero point position
direct response and good feedback only
one engine is available for the Civic
Sedan a 1.5 litre 134 kilowatt turbo
gasoline engine the 1800 rpm frisky
powertrains already puts two hundred and
forty Newton meters of torque on the
crankshaft and keeps going up to 5500
rpm so the Civic Sprint's from zero to
100 in 8.2 seconds if you use the manual
6-speed transmission the optional CVT
automatic transmission accelerates a
little more slow
the sedan takes its technology and
comfort features from the hatchback and
apart from being 13 centimeters longer
and having a sedan form it looks a lot
like the hatchback
in front the sedan sports abroad chrome
bar where the classic Civic has a black
panel and oversized honeycomb air
intakes
conspicuous c-shaped taillights give the
car's rear a well-integrated appearance
by the Honda Civic Honda calls this
version of the Civic and notchback sedan
says Ronny where is the knotch
voice digital filing glitch news flowing
lines make it looks more like if you
play and now for a look in that shrunk
one disadvantage of such lines is that
they greatly restrict the size of the
lead making it harder to load the trunk
but the trunk volume is quite adequate
Ronny just wishes the lid wouldn't if
you fold down the backseat storage space
increases from 500 to a spacious 1,200
liters
the interior is identical to that of the
hatchback variant
the seats contribute to the cars sporty
impression
and that's for martyrdom Ronnie says the
Honda Civic Sedan is shorter than the
Accord the new Civic generation is
bigger than its predecessor and so it
fills a gap Ronnie judges that the Civic
Sedan will appeal to many drivers thus
disagreements in civic indulgent kuta
songs number